good morning and thank you for coming
my name is john pelletier i'm a captain
with the las vegas metropolitan police
department
and i oversee the major violator and
narcotics bureau
we're here this morning because of the
alarming increase that this community
has seen
in overdose deaths last year last year
alone we had a 30 percent increase
from 591 to
768.
what's even more shocking is we had just
under a 2
200 percent increase in fentanyl
related deaths from 74
to 219
to put it in perspective in august alone
we had 31 deaths that is
a death a day from fentanyl
this emergency this situation
does not discriminate it does not care
how old you are
it does not care where you live we have
responded to teenagers
we have responded to the elderly you can
see from the map
right here all the places in this
community that we have gone
what's truly horrible about this is it's
completely preventable
every single one of these did not have
to happen
one bad pill will
kill again one bad pill
will kill if you are not prescribed
that drug from a pharmacist and doctor
do not take it
fentanyl is often disguised as a
prescription pill
but it can be up to 100 times
more potent than morphine or heroin
people that die from fentanyl
believe they are taking a prescription
grade pill
but they are taking a street or
pressed pill that was made who knows
where
with who knows what and the bottom line
is
they didn't know what they were taking
if you look
you can see a mixture of
press pills real pills they look real
enough
and what people don't understand is that
amount next to the penny
is what it takes to be fatal
because of this local law enforcement
and prosecutors came together to create
the overdose
response team members of the team
along with lvmpd include the district
attorney
the u.s attorney the dea
the coroner's office nevada haida
henderson hsi
we came together and the mission of the
overdose response team is to reduce
fatal and non-fatal overdose instances
to develop investigative leads to help
find those that are perpetrating this
and to prosecute them
and please understand we are working
with local and federal
prosecutors so that we can do the
absolute most
possible and if possible we will charge
you with murder
and a minimum for that is 20-year
sentence
also if you or someone
you know has a substance abuse problem
please seek help before it's too late
there are multiple resources available
if you need to know where they are you
can simply go to lvmpd.com
click on the resource or helpful link
and the we care booklet
do not allow a loved one or yourself
to become a statistic if you know
someone selling
or manufacturing illegal narcotics
and you wish to remain anonymous you can
call crime stoppers at 702-385-5555
thank you
so in 2019 you had 591 overdose deaths
in 2020 you had 768.
in 2019 fentanyl deaths you had 74
in 2020 you had 219.
so far this year not good i mean just
that's why we're here it's it's
if you knew an intersection had a death
a day at that intersection the public
would be screaming
what are we doing we had a death a day
for fentanyl
in august and so we're coming together
screaming
do not take those pills
sir
one can certainly make the argument that
you're staying at home
but the problem is these
precursors are available and people are
using them to manufacture
the the press pills do you want to make
an argument that
it the shutdown made it easier i don't
know that we have enough information
we've seen a trend
coming for several years but it's make
no mistake we said fentanyl was coming
fentanyl is here
okay thank you